ومعنا من غلاف غزه الان مراسلتنا نجوان
سمرين نجوان كنا نتابع صور مباشره تاتينا
من منطقه غلاف غزه وتظهر تصاعدا لاعمده
الدخان واستمرار لعمليات القصف وايضا
العاجل نشاهده نقلا عن مراسلتنا غاره على
موقع مواقع في شرق مدينه غزه يبدو بان هذه
الصور هي تظهر هذه المواقع اذا انفجارات
عنيفه في مدينه غزه دوي
سمع وذلك نقلا عنك نجوان ايه قربين اكثر
من ما
يجري بالفعل سلمى عده غارات نفذها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الدقائق الاخيره
الماضيه على احياء ومواقع مختلفه نستطيع
ان نرصدها من هذه المواقع المقابله
للاحياء الشرقيه في مدينه غزه عده غارات
عده انفجارات ايضا نسمع مع دويها من هنا
جراء عمليات القصف المتواصله على هذه
المواقع وبنفس الوقت ايضا تاتينا اصوات
انفجارات وقصف مدفعي عنيف يطال احياء في
الى الجنوب من مدينه غزه ربما في منطقه
جحر الديك
والمناطق القريبه من تلك المواقع
كالمغنيسيوم
من هذه المواقع ربما تستطيعون سماع ذ تلك
الاصوات للانفجارات العنيفه وتاتي من
مواقع مختلفه جزء منها من المواقع
الشماليه وتحديدا هنا في الاحياء الشرقيه
لمدينه غزه وايضا من المناطق الجنوبيه وما
نستطيع ان نحدده ان نحدده من هنا هي مناطق
جنوب مدينه غزه هذا بطبيعه الحال يترافق
مع تحليق للطيران الحربي ومسيرات عسكريه
على طول خط الحدود ايضا في المناطق
الشماليه عندما تواجدنا صباح هذا اليوم في
منطقه الغلاف القريبه من منطقتي بيت حانون
وبيت لاهيه كان هناك تحليق مكثف للطيران
الحربي تحديدا للمسيرات العسكريه و رافقه
قصف مدفعي استهدف مواقع مختلفه في تلك
المناطق وبالتالي من الواضح بان عمليات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتواصل ايضا في
المناطق الشماليه التي كان قد اعلن بانه
ايه قلل او تراجعت عملياته العسكريه
المكثفه في تلك المناطق وهذا ايضا ما
ينعكس في بيانه صباح هذا اليوم الذي تحدث
عن ال 24 ساعه الماضيه عن عمليات الجيش في
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وذكر ان هناك مواجهات
واشتباكات دارت ايضا في المناطق الشماليه
تحديدا في منطقه مخيم الشاطئ وفي بيانها
الصباحي قال ب بان قوات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اي قتلت سبعه مسلحين من كتائب
القسام في تلك المنطقه تحديدا لكنه ما زال
يكرر في بياناته ايضا الصباحيه ان غالبيه
القتال والمعارك والمواجهات تدور في
المناطق الجنوبيه في منطقه غرب وجنوب
مدينه خان يونس وهناك تحدث عن عده وقائع
ومواجهات دارت ووقعت بين قوات الاحتلال
وبين المقاومين الفلسطينيين ما يعني بان
الجيش ما زال يواجه في مدينه خانيونس
تحديدا قتالا ضاريا واشتباكات واسعه وهذا
ايضا ما جاء او انعكس على عدد الجنود
الذين قتلوا صباح هذا اليوم تم الاعلان عن
مقتل جندي اخر من وحده الهندسه في ال في
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايه بالاضافه
بطبيعه الحال الى ارتفاع متواصل في عدد
اصابات الجنود والضباط في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي والجيش يواصل ويقول بانه
يستهدف المسلحين في كل موقع ويقوم بعمليات
دهم لمواقع تابعه لحركات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا لكتائب القسام و ويدمر
بنى تحتيه تابعه ل للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
سلمى شكرا جزيلا لك من غلاف نجوان سمري